oh [__] okay oo wow all right so we have
Teran resonance uh Afro
Samurai uh helling Death Note One outs
what's the left on that looks familiar
uh there's there's one thing that stands
out to me yeah oh my God I just saw uh
tennis [__] coku and we got hand shakers
in the bottom right which is one of the
one of the worst animes of it's one of
the worst shows ever made for is that
hand shakers or is that whiz I can't
hand shakers this has to be shindo L
right you reckon I don't know if it is I
really you know I love shindo and I
really hope he doesn't say oh wait
no I think it might be mood you know why
cuz Mudan told me he loved hand shakers
one time what yeah and I was like wait
isn't that like the worst anime of the
year when it came out he like yeah so
this is definitely mood I [__] with one
outs though one outs is is great sick
sick is this is this mood on oh my my
God Mudan why the [__] you put hand
shakers on there I I saw hand shakers
and I was like I it's either shindell or
Mudan and I'm leaning more towards Mudan
just because um from a visual standpoint
like from a purely visual standpoint
it's pretty impressive how shout out to
go hands yeah it's it's pretty
impressive how bad something can be on a
from a visual standpoint it's it's not
like it's it's not like it's bad
um and nobody because nobody's trying
someone is trying the team is trying
really hard to make something look
visually interesting yeah the team said
how many textures you the direct yes
didn't it look [__] and they just added
way too many different textures so it
just looks horrendous they they added
way too many textures and I think at
that point they discovered like uh
Dynamic camera movement and they tried
using that [__] for everything it's it's
like the equivalent of you know when
you're making your first PowerPoint
presentation and you learn about the
star WIP transition
s that's what what it like do that with
every single and all the text is in word
art that's that's that's what it's like
rainbow font word art so so what are the
what's the the three in the bottom left
corner what are those three the one with
the orb oh the the orb one yeah what's
that one Hy that is henery and that is a
[__] great
series and then Prince of Tennis Prince
of
Tennis I don't know much about Co
um I would be very very interesting all
I know is that the opening is one of my
favorite openings from that uh from that
year in fact it an absolute Banger
opening watched the first four episodes
and I don't remember anything about it
what was that show about some it was
time travel thing was it time travel I'm
not sure I don't even remember I also
maybe watched like the first two or
three episodes and then didn't that's
surprising That's a classic I thought
that was I haven't met anyone who said
that's their favorite sports anime you'd
be surprised a lot of people in ja I
know in Japan it's very popular yeah
it's huge but in the western it's one of
my I would say like guilty pleasure
Sports Anime because the the one thing
that Prince of Tennis and a lot of
Sports Anime does that I personally
don't really like is the whole like
[__] power up thing I [__] love
that in Sports Anime but the but shows
like Prince of Tennis do it in a way
where it's just [__] didn't hit like
the like a hit like the sun or something
or no he okay okay so let me let me
explain which one do you start with let
me let me explain the play by play cuz I
know exactly the one you're talking
about I might have talked about this
before but there is a scene where one of
the powers is Tesa Tes Zone he has a
power called Tesa zone right and uh the
power the power is no matter where you
want the ball to go when you return it
to him the ball will always spin towards
his zone of control right so that's so
that's the power so the visual metaphor
that they go
that they go to huh orbit is that so
Tesa is like kind of like the beginning
of everything the start of the universe
basically this is okay uh every time you
hit a ball it always orbits around him
and then the balls turn into planets
that turn into the Galaxy that turn into
the universe and tessica started the big
bang and the Big Bang turns into a
tennis ball I think and then he hits the
tennis ball and then the ball turns into
an asteroid that wipes out the
dinosaurs oh that's sick so so good it's
like seph's final attack it's so good
but like that's the thing it's like
Prince Prince at tennis and uh and Ice
shield 21 are the two sports shows in my
opinion where these like completely
unrealistic [__] powerups just make
for some of the most
entertaining [__] Powers too see I
thought Kroos was just kind of whatever
I like them I like them yeah I like them
I wish I wish Kuro went further like
Prince of Tennis did I actually the when
it was when Prince of Tennis started
going a little bit further that it
started to lose me really um yeah I
think tesone was like funny um I mean I
wasn't taking that scene seriously at
all I didn't take the entire show
seriously there was a point where I took
it seriously um and then I kind of
realized number one uh I think I [__]
despise the main
character is he a dick or like why okay
like I just I I was I was with him until
it kind of made me realize that he's
like this like 11 12y old Prodigy who's
just so [__] cocky and uh arrogant
and I'm like man imagine if he existed
in real life and you imagine 11 12 year-
old going mother mother yeah exactly
that's what I was saying he points his
[__] Dennis racket at you and uh you
do
and I'm like you are 12 and I'm like you
listen to you little
[__] shut
up yeah um but like prin said uh Prince
of Tennis was actually my first Sports
Anime as well I I still have a lot of
nostalgia over it but I can't it was fun
it was stupid fun I can't say it's
better than other sports anime that I've
watched after Prince of Tennis that's
why I say it's kind of like my guilty
pleasure Sports show cuz it's like a
sports show that's so ridiculous that
you can't take it seriously and it just
goes beyond the Sports Anime I love that
we have death note and Sports Death Note
on here yeah one outs I love one outs so
much one outs is such an underrated
Sports Anime it's it's not many people
talk about it anymore but this is my
kind of like pick for a Sports Anime
that not not enough people have watched
so good and I still think the quality is
there if you want to watch Death Note
but uh with the Death Note logic applied
to baseball watch one outs does Mudan
have uh opinions no you didn't get any
okay cuz like Afro Samurai is an
interesting pick I mean it's a [__]
fantastic show but I've never heard him
even mentioning Afro Samurai I mean the
fact that Samuel Jackson voices oh yeah
uh English is produce crazy I'm not sure
actually he was I think he was like one
of the lead staff in that I think he
either wrote it or produced it or
something I've actually never watched it
I just know that Sam Jackson voices him
oh you would love it really you would
love it it's such a good show uh helling
is like I mean yeah who doesn't like
Hing I love the dub of helling
English is so [__] good it's just
it's just [__] hand shakers like why
I I can see why he likes it really I
mean it's I can't see why anyone would
like it m loves bad things yeah he loves
I get that cuz he loves he he loves
weird [__] no I get that but like you
know there's I have a lot of shows that
I love where it's like it's so bad that
it's good but handshake is wasn't even
it's so so bad that it's good it's just
so bad on a visual perspective which
even a storytelling perspective well a
storytelling perspective I think was
just very I can't power up unless I'm
touching a girl's hand that's literally
the entire premise of hand storytelling
perspective was very generic you know
but from a visual perspective it is it
is actually like incredible I'd like to
imagine that he's rebuttal all that
we're saying in the in the yeah the text
notes right
here wram would say something like he'd
look at you dead in the face and go yeah
and it's awesome they hold hands that's
what he would say that was a really good
mood yeah
I do like how out of everything here
there's just this nice fuel good anime
that's H matery you know I never
actually watched it what if if there's
if there's one hand shakers isn't the
thing that uh stands out to me the most
in this one uh because it's actually H
maty cuz it proves to me that Mudan
isn't a robot he's a yeah he's a human
with the emotions cuz everything else
I'm like ah okay this is like only an AI
could enjoy hand shakers you know I can
I can understand the enjoyment uh from
from just a purely fascinating from from
a purely technical perspective that is
[__] fascinating H matery is just so
[__]
Feelgood um it looks feel good it's yeah
it's it's would you recommend I would
actually recommend I I only the only
thing the only reason I think that more
people didn't talk about it was because
it came out in a year that was an
absolute Banger of anime years in in
terms of shows coming out just got swept
under the rug um but it's one of those
shows that does this whole you know
showing the relationship between a
father and a daughter really really well
if you watch H marser you will and you
are a father uh and you have a daughter
this is this is the show for you cuz uh
it'll make so it's aagi drop with a good
ending it's not it's not even good yeah
yeah yeah yeah kind of yeah all right
all right you sold me all right cool
thanks moving on let's do the next I'm
looking forward to the amount of [__]
he's going to talk a lot of death notes
on the list so and Terror residence as
well I think that's the second is that
third time we've seen Death Note now or
second